I've seen no evidence of special
relationship you're just going to have
to show me any evidence I think the
special relationship does exist in some
cases I think it's been an abusive
relationship I don't think we want a
special relationship with the Trump
administration I also don't think is
that important necessarily for trade
there goes that relationship I think the
relationship is is strong given history
of the relationship and I think it'll be
strong going forward the special
relationship undoubtedly does exist and
has a profound impact on shaping global
politics this one Atlantic Alliance
between two countries and bookended by
two wars the Second World War and the
Iraq war has shaped international law
and global governance for over half a
century we're allies and we do have a
special relationship and I feel it I
talk to everybody I talk to cab drivers
I talk to people work on the street I've
talked to all of pretty much I lived two
years in Washington DC and hunting for
any other dancers I could find none and
asked people who were supposed to be in
charge of relations between Britain the
United States what the special
relationship was they didn't know I
think we should just not be so
sentimental about it our low point I
think is pretty self-evident
it was Tony Blair being I guess what we
would call the lapdog of president
george w bush what we saw is a British
prime minister completely forfeit his
own legitimacy in terms of representing
the views of his a lecturer by going
along with a political vision that was
being set by the United States we
therefore here in Britain stand shoulder
to shoulder with our American friends in
this hour of tragedy the United States
completely trampled on our interest in
Ireland and gave a visa to Gerry Adams
that in my view led to a surrender to
the IRA a few years later very much
under American pressure if that's a
special relationship it's especially bad
relationship the most effective
relationship between a president and the
Prime Minister was undoubtedly Ronald
Reagan and Margaret Thatcher I'm not
sure that any US president
Primus has ever had a particularly good
relationship because they really did so
about remaking the global economy in
their own vision the reagan-thatcher
relationship is perhaps the best example
of two leaders who will get along who
will have this special relationship in
their hearts but who will put their own
people and the interest of their own
nations first always
I think Barrack Obama's intervention in
the British European referendum was an
act of grave political folly because our
focus is in negotiating with a big block
the European Union to get a trade
agreement done and UK is gonna be in the
back of the queue that is a line that
has come straight from 10 Downing Street
and been read by Barack Obama I was
surprised I've always thought that I
don't agree with him on many things that
Obama was an intelligent person I was
surprised to the allowed himself to do
something so crass I think he actually
handed us the referendum he handed
brexit for the referendum by doing that
I thought brexit I think and I think
it'll go down that it will end up being
a fantastic thing for the United Kingdom
what this Donald Trump presidency has
brought not just to the special
relationship but actually to the
American relationship with the entirety
of Europe is the idea that you can be a
sovereign independent nation state but
there can be European nations out there
that can look after their own defence
budgets and look after their own
sovereignty well from a sedimentary
perspective Trump has Scottish ancestry
his mother is from Scotland and loved
the royal family and I think that
instills in him his love for the Queen
and respect for the UK watch this
I'm not sure that Donald Trump really
has a relationship with reason made
foreign leaders at him incidents in his
day he has to cope with certainly they
probably would not be the two people
that you've picked out to become the
best of friends
but they are working in challenging
times and they have different priorities
for their countries we are going to have
a policy America first
I think the phrase America first is an
absolutely phenomenal phrase it doesn't
say America only you see the way
President Trump is running his foreign
policy the deals he's doing in North
Korea the deals he's doing in the Middle
East John Trump is an erratic person I
don't he has any particular guiding
ideology or even a set of beliefs apart
from his own personal success
understanding all of these things are
run contrary to the idea that America
first is an isolationist policy and I
think we should have the same thing in
the United Kingdom too Trump has great
value and respect for the UK as
demonstrated by one of his first actions
of restoring the bust of Winston
Churchill to the Oval Office which was
removed by Obama he also invited Teresa
May to be the first foreign leader to
visit the White House and putting the UK
at the top of the list for a post brexit
trade deal I mean the saddest thing
about the Trump presidency is that it
hasn't actually weakened the special
relationship between governments at all
as the President himself has said I
think we have already struck up a good
good relationship so we've been treated
to the sad spectacle of our prime
minister to resume capering after Donald
Trump in indefensible policy matters and
even holding his hand I think that
unfortunately that special relationship
is intact at the expense of people on
both sides of the Atlantic I'm really
not sure why the British government
feels the need to suck up to Donald
Trump it just looks to me as if we're
we're just basing ourselves before a
more important path I doubt we'll get
anything out of it I think we shouldn't
do this sort of thing either to Donald
Trump or to Saudi Arabia or lots of
other countries we do
[Music]